rachel nichols jimmy you guys were
severely undermanned coming into this
game playing a team with two of the top
five players in the nba and yet you told
me before
tip off i think we have figured
something out how were you able to do
this tonight
we rebounded that that's gonna be the
key going forward
we gotta keep those guys off the boards
limit their second chance points we got
back pretty well
um it also helps to make shots so never
get me wrong but i'm glad we get some
people back
you had a 40 point triple double tonight
in an nba finals game that is the best
game of your career
so far what was your mindset throughout
every minute
when i don't care about a trip i don't
care about none of that i really don't
i want to win we did that i'm happy with
the outcome
how have you guys reset this series now
that it's two to one
uh i think we realize that we belong
that they can't be beat
as long as we do what we're supposed to
do um but uh coming the next game i know
they're gonna be so much better
and we gotta be able to match that
energy congratulations jimmy butler
appreciate you
thanks mike back to you all right rachel
only four times in finals history
as the team won the title after trailing
two games to none in the finals one of
those was 2006
the miami heat that's when dwyane wade
was extraordinary
brought them back against the dallas
mavericks well jimmy butler without two
of his key star players
out for the second straight game with an
injury puts on a performance for the
ages